c'est un mastodonte en construction
depuis trois ans le complexe des
sciences se dévoile c'est la
concrétisation du plus grand chantier
universitaire au canada c'est soixante
mille mètres carrés 650 1000 pieds
carrés l'équivalent de plus de 300
maisons familiales ce comme un quartier
un quartier qui accueillera deux mille
étudiants 200 professeurs et chercheurs
dans quatre domaines chimie physique
géographie et sciences biologiques
actuellement les cadets partira sont
éparpillés sur le campus de la montagne
dans des édifices dans les bâtiments
différents
donc c'est pour la première fois que les
sciences naturelles vont se retrouver un
regroupés sous le même toit
ça va vraiment bien j'ai fait la visite
de nos laboratoires puis on est vraiment
plus d'espoir on a besoin d'avoir plus
de jeunes qui choisissent les sciences
parce que c'est là que ça se passe
l'innovation françois legault y voient
un symbole de richesse
il veut que les chercheurs
universitaires se rapproche des
entreprises privées pour commercialiser
la recherche
il imagine ici quelque chose comme une
silicon valley québécoise quand on
regarde la recherche au québec on est
parmi les meilleurs au monde quand on
regarde le nombre de brevets donc
l'enregistrement pour eva traînement
commercialiser la recherche on est
inculte l'attend
mais autour du complexe des sciences
certains sont inquiets ils craignent que
le campus mais ils ne fassent exploser
le prix des loyers
il a des conséquences à l'implantation
du campus mille ici bas sur ce site là
et on est juste à côté d'une
d'un quartier le cat tien des quartiers
les plus pauvres du canada parc
extension
je trouve ça très triste qu'on soit à
l'ouverture du campus 1000 et que les
administrations précédentes et pas
penser à ça avant on aurait dû avoir
déjà une stratégie pour s'assurer que
tout auto on est capable de loger tout
le monde elle promet des dizaines de
logements sociaux à proximité pour que
tous étudiants et résidents profitent de
la revitalisation du secteur en plein
coeur de lille ici sébastien desrosiers
radio-canada mourir